it gives me great pleasure to attend
here the Gathering the weekend of
lectures at this Masid the Islamic
Center of Palm Beach Florida we ask
Allah to accept it from us and to make
this knowledge appr proov for us and not
against us indeed these types of
gatherings are extremely important
Gatherings
where the book of Allah is discussed the
son of our beloved Messengers sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is discussed and the
people are reminded of our obligations
toward our Lord and our obligations
toward our religion
and indeed as time goes on we realize
the importance of these types of
gatherings as evil becomes more
widespread and as individuals get
further and further away from their lord
we need to be
reminded Allah says in the
Quran Allah said
that the time for the Reckoning of the
people has approached and become near
and they are
heedless they are
heedless so indeed it's upon the
Believers those who ascribe to Islam
it's upon the Believers to attend
Gatherings of
remembrance upon the Believers to
benefit so that we can believe in in
save ourselves from
the from the destruction that Allah has
promised
mankind when
saidel and by time mankind is lost and
Mankind is in a state of
Destruction except those righteous deeds
and to come together and come together
upon patience and come together upon the
truth so it's upon the Believers to come
together upon the
truth as Allah
says join together upon righteousness
and piety and do not join together upon
sin and
transgression so indeed these types of
gatherings are extremely important so we
ask Allah to bless the brothers the
sisters the families the community for
their sincere
efforts also what reminds the
Believers of the importance of these
types of
gatherings is what's reported the Hadith
which is reported in the
sun of ma while beloved Messengers
sallahu alai mentioned as is reported
by the companion that the prophet s
alaihi wasallam
said the Islam would become more
strange and rare like the wearing of the
clothing you have a piece of clothing
and you wear it and you wash it you wear
it you wash it becomes
weak doesn't have that same new
feeling so the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam said Islam will become rare
and
uncommon just like the wearing of the
throat it becomes worn and torn and the
likes then the prophet sallam
said until a time comes that the prayer
is
unknown fasting is
unknown H is unknown charity is
unknown and will come a time where these
things are Unknown People don't know
them
anymore and Allah would decree that a
time comes that the Quran is
lifted and it no longer
remains then the prophet
said
and you will have old people
remaining you have individuals old men
and old women they say we heard we
recall our parents saying this
statement so we say it because they they
used to say it so my dear brothers and
sisters can you imagine that there will
be a time where light is no longer
present fasting H charity the religion
is lost the only thing that people
remember from the religion and these are
the
Muslims the only thing that people
recall from the religion is I recall my
forefather saying let not so I
Sayed so these types of and that Hadith
is declared authentic
by so these types of gatherings are
extremely important to remind the
Believers the brothers the sisters the
families the children to remind them
what is
Islam we see our children practicing
praying learning they will come a time
the children walk the
religion another narration in Muslim
with the prophet s
said Islam began as a religion which was
stret
and Islam will return to be a religion
which is
strange any we see it's like today the
fastest growing religion in the world
and individuals unexpected becoming
Muslim the prophet said Islam will
return to becoming to be a St religion
it will
return and you add the statements of the
scatters when they mention
this about Islam becoming strange War
once
again as it was
mentioned by IMI one of the great
Scholars who gave an explanation to that
Hadith he
said the reason why or the understanding
of the Prophet sallallahu alai wasallam
saying Islam will return to being
something strange he said this
indicates how few the people are who
Implement
Islam there will become a time there
will become a time that very few people
Implement Islam and support Islam even
though there are many Muslims but those
who truly hold on to the religion and
practice the religion they will be very
few they will be very
few and it was also mentioned
by the standing committee for f and
Saudi Arabia
when it was headed
by he said or they
said he said when the prophet said that
Islam began is something strange and it
will end as something strange this is
not because they are small in
number this is not because they are
small in number you have many
individuals that ascribe to Islam
but the reason why Islam will become
something
strange is because individuals no longer
hold on to their
religion and they no longer abide by the
book of their lord so that's what will
happen in the latter days individuals
will no longer hold on to their religion
they will no longer abide by the book of
their lord to
so my dear brothers and sisters it's
very important that we have these types
of gatherings to remind the Believers of
our obligations in the religion and our
o our obligations toward our Lord and
toward the book of Allah and toward the
sun of our beloved Messenger
s indeed my brothers and sisters the
topic that was
selected for us to discuss about
the movement or the
LGBT plus movement is a very important
topic and it's a topic that would take
days to
discuss because it's such a vast topic
but we want to highlight a few things
about this movement because maybe some
of us are
unaware and as we have the
statement of the
companion where he
said and his father were
Muslim said that the people used to ask
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
about the
good and I used I used to ask the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam about
the
evil out a fear of it reaching me
so who wanted to know about the evil he
wanted to know the specifics so that he
could be
cautious so Our
intention Our intention is to highlight
some in this short period of time some
of the aspects related to this movement
so that the Muslims can be aware and so
that the Muslims can be
cautious and it's also mentioned an
example of that was also mentioned in
the biography
of it was mentioned
that when he would speak about eward
people would think that he and he from
his indepth knowledge
other they would think that he indulged
in but he did not indulge in it but the
scholars of of Islam are very much aware
of the FNA so that they can warn the
people of
it
so with regards to some of the things
that we will mention about this movement
from the first things we want to mention
is that this is not something
new this is not something new this type
of movement
or is this type of understanding or this
these types of indecent actions it's not
something new in fact it's mentioned in
the book of
Allah in several places in the story
of and his people in the story of M and
his people and it's very important that
the Believers benefit from that story
and the stories of the prophets because
as they say history repeats
itself and there are
lessons to be learned from the people of
n which is similar to the actions of the
people today the promoters and the
callers to this movement and those who
supported there's some of the things
that were done by the people of loot
that are presently being done by the
supporters and the promoters of this
movement
today from that which and stories of the
prophet is very important that we do
benefit from the stories of the prophets
and Messengers we learn from them Allah
did not just mention them just to
mention them for recreation and the
likes where Allah mentioned those
stories so that we can benefit from for
example
in
says Allah says inah which is one of the
prophets and all of them the prophets
and The Messengers we inform you of
their
stories so that your heart can be
firm that we and Allah is speaking to
his Prophet Muhammad alai was but Allah
is also speaking to his followers so
Allah
mentions various stories of the prophets
and The Messengers and what they went
through and what they endured so that
our hearts can be framed we go through
trial and tribulation they went through
bra of Trials and tribulations then
Allah
says Allah says and in it in these
stories you have
truth you have lessons and you have
reminders Allah mentions you have truth
you have lessons and you have reminders
so in the stories of the prophets and
specifically we're going to mention some
of the benefits from the story of N and
his
people right you have the the truth
there's no doubt about it you have
lessons and you have a reminder and
that's why we said history repeats
itself things they did then things
they're doing now things they did
then and they the movement today hasn't
done it yet but they will do
it Allah also says Allah also says
in
Allah
said indeed you have a
reminder for people of understanding in
the story of yusf and Allah mentions
this at the end of the story of Yousef
indeed you have a reminder for the
people of understanding it is not a
madeup
story but it is to confirm that which
has been
presented and specifics and guidance and
mercy for the people who understand
people of understanding so Allah is
reminding Us in the stories of the
prophets we have a reminder we have
lessons we have details so we should pay
attention
from the story that we wanted to
mention the story of
L and you have it mentioned in different
places in the Quran
in
in other places in the Quran you have
Allah mentioning the story of
n
in Allah
said
said Allah said and
L when n said to his
people would you do such an atrocious
action or sin that you have not been
preceded by anyone from the
creation you have not been preceded by
anyone from amongst the
creation right so this action that was
being
performed of
indecency Allah mentioned that
when said this to his people loot
informed them no none of the
creation none of the creation that came
before you have ever performed such an
indecency so they were the first people
to perform this
indecency
and just to give us a background about
in his book of he mentioned
that that lot his name lot the son of
Haron the son of azer he is the son of
the brother of ibraim
and remember
ibim ibraim his father's name was AZ
L
is he is the nephew of
ibim lam was the nephew of ibraim and he
was sent to this people
sud lot was the nephew of ibraim and
when ibraim called his people to to
Faith his nephew accepted it and we know
that ibraim his father didn't we know
that
ibraim his father as did not he rejected
it he rejected the da of ibraim but
ibrahim's nephew
accepted Allah selected ibrahim's nephew
to be a prophet and to send him to
sud and this was a village in the area
of sham and he approached them and he
called them to to and he called them to
worship of Allah and he called them to
abandon this indecent action
which was
homosexuality which was
homosexuality
and pay attention to this statement of
half
of he
said no one before them no one prior to
them from amongst the humans nor anyone
else
any very important point he said not the
humans or anyone else the Jin and the
lights they were not preceded by anyone
in this action they were not preceded by
anyone in this action he
said
said the humans have never witnessed nor
have they experiened nor could they ever
fathom doing this type of action before
they did it it was never even on their
mind of doing this type of action until
they did it and then said upon them is
the curse of
Allah so that's something we must
understand this action
was not performed before the people of L
not by the humans nor anyone else nor
anyone else they did not even Fab or
imagine doing this type of action but
another thing we understand is that
these people doing it now they're not
the first to do it and this is not
something that just came about during
the time of the Prophet Prophet L
hundreds thousands of years before the
prophet Muhammad s. was so there actions
are is mentioned in the Quran it's
mentioned in the
Quran and another thing and for the
brothers and sisters to know that in the
story of L and in the different books of
T it's mentioned that it wasn't only the
men with
men it wasn't only the men with men
their actions of indecency was not just
men with men their actions of indecency
were men with
men and also men approaching women in a
manner which was not acceptable y in the
anus and women with women it's mentioned
in various books of T that these were
the three actions men with men men
approaching women in their rear
ends and women with women that was the
actions of the people of
L another thing
to show you the severity of these
individuals during their time similar to
what they're doing now or what it is
assumed that they will do when L called
his people to
righteousness called his people to
believe in Allah Asel obey Allah worship
Allah alarm and to need this action of
indecency they did not say to L just
leave us
alone we have our beliefs you have your
beliefs right they did not say that to
loot rather what they said to loot as
Allah
said
when called these people to believe in
Allah and to abandon their actions they
gathered and they came up with a
response they said get them out of our
land banish them we don't want them to
be around us because they are clean
people they are clean people so notice
they did not
suffice with you have your beliefs we
have our beliefs you disagree we
disagree no problem we can coexist
no they said get them out of our land we
no longer want them to live with us
because they are clean people they are
clean people
IM one of the great Scholars of he
said they criticize them for no reason
and what is their crime why do you want
to banish these people out of your land
what crime have they committed because
because they're
clean because they don't do the actions
that you
do right it was also
mentioned
by that
[Music]
said they had
no said they had no
response nor objection except they
wanted to get rid of
them they wanted to get rid of them they
Loot and they wanted to get rid of the
Believers they did not want them to live
amongst
them and like we said history repeats
itself it was also mentioned by a sassan
one of the great Scholars the later
Scholars
of he he
said what's intended by this
verse they meant that these people
meaning Luke and his followers they are
clean they are pure they don't do what
we do so they should not live with us in
our
city they should no longer live with us
in our city so my dear brothers and
sisters we take an example from that and
we take a lesson from that it's not that
they feel that they have their beliefs
and you have your beliefs no you
disagree with them
no here they wanted to remove Loot and
the
Believers and now similar we find it
coming up
discrimination hate if you don't like us
you're
discriminating if you don't like us
these are hate this is hate
speech this is you're you're not
tolerant it will increase until it gets
to this point get rid of them they
should no longer be in the land that we
live in you will begin to hear them say
we feel
threatened right we feel
uncomfortable that's what you begin to
hear them say it will continue to
develop until it here history repeats
itself may Allah protect us
all